your majesty congratulations on your  platinum jubilee  for 70 years you've inspired people with  your selfless devotion and service to  the people of the united kingdom and the  commonwealth  throughout your reign the relationship  between the united kingdom and the  united states has grown stronger and  closer than ever throughout the years  the joy your visits to the united states  have brought americans and your  solidarity with the american people in  times of tragedy  have deepened the friendship and  profound connection between our  countries  and joe and i were so touched by the  generosity and welcome you showed us  when we visited you at windsor castle  last year during our first visit  overseas as president and first lady on  behalf of the people of the united  states we send you our best wishes to  you and the people around the world  marking this momentous and historic  occasion  congratulations your majesty and have a  wonderful platinum jubilee celebration